[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليالي الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العناوين
تصعد يسبق الهدنه بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه
والجيش الاسرائيلي ونتنياهو يقول ان
المعركه لم تنتهي بعد
فهمت مقدم
الملك سلمان يوجه دعوه للرئيس السوري
لحضور قمه الجامعه العربيه القادمه في جده
اشتباكات واصوات انفجارات عنيفه في
الخرطوم والتدهور الامني يؤدي لانتشار
السطو والنهب
تحسبا لتصعيد محتمل من انصار عمران خان
الحكومه الباكستانيه تطالب الجيش بالتدخل
لحفظ الامن
[موسيقى]
تصعيد يسبق الهدنه هذا عنوان ما يحصل الان
بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه والجيش الاسرائيلي
صواريخ من غزه باتجاه تل ابيب وبئر السبع
تقول الاخيره انها تصدت لها عبر القبه
الحديديه تارا ومنظومه مقلاع داوود
قال ان المعركه لم تنتهي بعد وان قواته
تستهدف حاليا اهدافا لحركه الجهات في غزه
فيما دفعت الصواريخ الفلسطينيه بالالاف من
الاسرائيليين للهروب الى الملاجئ كما
تسببت بتعطيل الملاحه الجويه بمطار بن
غوريان وقبل ذلك تدخلت القاهره وقررت
ارسال وفود الى اسرائيل وغزه للاتفاق على
هدنه طويله الامد بانتظار تطبيقها
سكروا لي
اذا ان مصادر للعربيه اشارت الى نجاح
الجهود المصريه في التوصل الى هدنه بين
اسرائيل والفلسطينيين وانهاء جوله التصعيد
الحاليه في غزه وقالت المصادر للعربيه ان
اسرائيل ابلغت مصر موافقتها على التهدئه
ووقف تحليق الطيران العسكري في قطاع غزه
شرط وقف اطلاق الصواريخ من القطاع واضافت
المصادر ان مصر قررت ارسال وفود الى
اسرائيل وغزه لوضع الخطوط العريضه لهدنه
طويله الامد وذكرت المصادر ان مصر ترتب
الاستضافه اجتماعين منفصلين مع وفدي
الوفاء الفصائل الفلسطينيه واسرائيل
بالقاهره بعد استقرار الاوضاع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا قبل ان اكمل ساشير الى ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يطالب اسرائيل
والفلسطينيين بضبط النفس وحمايه المدنيين
اذا كانت هذه مطالبه الاتحاد الاوروبي
طبعا بعد مطالبات عربيه ودوليه بضروره ضبط
النفس وانهاء هذا الصراع بين الطرفين الى
جانب ذلك الخارجيه الفلسطينيه حملت
الحكومه الاسرائيليه المسؤوليه الكامله عن
اعدام مدنيين فلسطينيين خلال الهجوم على
قطاع غزه بين هؤلاء اطفال ونساء واضافت
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه انها تتابع مع الدول
والجهات الامميه ولجنه تحقيق المستمره
المنبثقه عن مجلس حقوق الانسان ورئاسه
اعضاء مجلس الامن الدولي لكشف الحقائق
وتوفير الحمايه للفلسطينيين وتنفيذ قرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من حدود قطاع غزازيات
حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد
كيف هي الصوره من على الحدود سوره التصعيد
بالساعات الاخيره وماذا عن دخول يعني
توقيت الهدنه
قبل خمس دقائق من هذا الاتصال الان لماذا
قبل خمس دقائق الان هناك على الهواء
مباشره يمكن ان ترى الصواريخ تنطلق من
شمال قطاع غزه الان
ثلاثه او اربعه صواريخ رايناها تنطلق اذا
والان هناك صاروخ ياتي باتجاهنا
وصواريخ اخرى ايضا تاتي يعني من ثلاثه
اتجاهات تاتي الصواريخ الى قطاع من قطاع
غزه تجاه مستوطنات الغلاف الان ستحاول
القبه الحديديه الاعتراض لبعض الصواريخ
هذا المشهد يتكرر في الساعتين الاخيرتين
تباعا اكثر من 80 صاروخا اطلقت في خلال
الساعتين الاخيرتين
سفارات الانذار تنطلق في معظم مستوطنات
غلاف غزه الان
زياد هل ممكن ان نبقي الصوره مفتوحه لو
سمحت
الان لا يحدث الكثير لهذا عدت الى الكادر
عمليا
كما كنت اقول
نقل حصل بالساعات الماضيه وباي توقيت
ستدخل الهدنه حيز التنفيذ
هذا صحيح في الساعتين الاخيرتين كما كنت
اقول نلاحظ اطلاق عشرات الصواريخ تباعا
بعض هذه الصواريخ يطلق اتجاه تل ابيب وسط
اسرائيل تجاه مدن مثل بئر السبع ومدن من
مثل ومناطق اخرى عمليا يعني من مدى من صفر
الى ثمانين كيلو مترا كانت التغطيه
الصاروخيه في الساعات الاخيره وايضا مع
بدء الرشقات التي بدات اليوم بدا العدد
يقترب من 400 صاروخ باعتقادي الان اذا ما
احتسبنا الرشقات الاخيره مع ما كان منذ
عمليا الساعات الماضيه هذا يقودنا في
المقابل طبعا اسرائيل تواصل شن الغارات
بين الحين والاخر في رفح جنوبا وهنا في
شمال قطاع غزه نرى هذا تباعا يحدث
نتنياهو طبعا في المؤتمر الصحافي قال ان
القتال مستمر المعركه مستمره وكذا ايضا
قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
وهذا امر كان متوقعا كما نعلم لان عمليا
عندما تطلق صواريخ على تل ابيب لا يستطيع
ان يقول نحن نقترب من وقف لاطلاق النار
وان كان الاعتقاد لدى المصادر المختلفه
على فكره لدى الجانبين بانما نشهده الان
هو ربما محاوله لرسم المشهد الختامي لهذه
الجوله من التصعيد بمعنى الجهاد من
ناحيتها تواصل اطلاق الصواريخ حتى اللحظه
الاخيره وعمليا تستهدف تل ابيب وليس فقط
مستوطنات غلاف قطاع غزه فيما ان اسرائيل
تواصل الغارات تباعا على المناطق المختلفه
الوساطه المصريه ناشطه جدا في الساعات
الاخيره عمليا وحتى مصادر رسميه في
اسرائيل قالت انها لا تستبعد التوصل الى
وقف لاطلاق النار في الساعات المقبله لكن
دائما وهذه من خلال التجربه في تغطيه مثل
هذه الجولات المتعاقبه من وتبادل القصف
بين الفصائل واسرائيل عاده في الساعات
الاخيره تكون الاخطر عمليا بسبب ما كنت
تتحدث عنه محاوله ترسيم او كي الوعي من
خلال المشهد الختام ان كان باطلاق
الصواريخ ذا تل ابيب او الغارات
الاسرائيليه المراقبون يرون الان بان
اسرائيل والفصائل لديها لدى كل طرف ما
يكفي ربما لوقف اطلاق النار لانه يستطيع
ان يقول لي قاعدته الداخليه بانه انجز
انجازا كبيرا نتنياهو سمعتم كيف كان يتحدث
في المؤتمر الصحافي اليوم يتحدث عن تغيير
المعادله عن الاغتيالات عن المبادره عن
السيطره على التوقيت للاغتيال بالنسبه
لاسرائيل وما الى ذلك رغم ان هذا الامر
كان قبل 19 فقط قام به لبيد هذا ما كان
رئيسا للوزراء بمعنى هذا تكرار لما قامت
به الحكومه السابقه عمليات الاغتيال وهناك
من ينتقد في اسرائيل على حياه ما يحدث
يقول ان الاغتيالات لو كانت ناجعه وتخلق
رضعا لما تكررت كل تسعه اشهر كما يحدث
الان على المقلب الاخر بالنسبه للجهاد
والفصائل تستطيع ان تقول بانها قصفت تل
ابيب مرات وافلحت في ربما حتى
تعطيل الملاحه الجويه في مطار بن غوريون
لعده ساعات هذا اليوم هذا الان هناك على
ما اعتقد صواريخ تنطلق من قطاع غزه
نعم نعم ومن الجهه الاخرى الان على الشاشه
سترون
ثياب به
ذه هذا صاروخ تم اعتراضه سنسمع الصوت بعد
قليل
وبعيد نسبيا
هذا فوق سديروت الاعتراض فوق مستوطنه
نحن نسمع سفارات الانذار حتى الان
هذا صحيح انطلاق سفارات الانذار في كل
مكان عمليا في غلاف غزه هذا المشهد عمليا
كما كنت اقول يتكرر في الساعات الاخيره
ونسمع ايضا حتى المقاتلات الاسرائيليه
عمليا ستكون هناك الان غارات على شمال
قطاع غزه من ثلاث مناطق تقريبا نلحظ اطلاق
الصواريخ يتكرر في كل مره من المنطقه
ذاتها نرى اطلاق عشرات الصواريخ عمليا
تجاه المستوطنات الاسرائيليه
عمليا ما يحدث في بعض الاحيان بان دفعه
كبيره من الصواريخ تطلق بهدف ان تحاول
القبه او ان تشغل القبه الحديديه بمحاوله
الاعتراض كي تمر صواريخ الاساسيه التي
تذهب الى اتجاه تل ابيب صواريخ الكبيره
عمليا كي تشق طريقها عمليا على علو كبير
هذا في بعض الاحيان التكتيك نراه في كل
المواجهات المتكرره بين اسرائيل والفصائل
الفلسطينيه كما قلت التقديرات على الاقل
حاليا رغم هذه المشاهد التي نراها على
لواء مباشره بين الحين والاخر بان
امكانيه وقف اطلاق النار ما تزال وارده
المصريون ابلغوا الطرفين بانهم يريدون
افاده وفد مصري في خلال ايام غزه وائل تل
ابيب كي يقوم باعاده الحوار على التهدئه
طويله الامد بطبيعه الحال كي يفهم المشاهد
عندما نتحدث عن وقف اطلاق نار لا يقصد به
اتفاق متكامل مع بنود وما الى ذلك ابدا لا
توقيع على هذا الاتفاق فقط التزام امام
وسيط المصري بوقف اطلاق النار في ساعه
معطى ومتفق عليها مثل منتصف الليل مثلا
وما الى ذلك
فنتابع معك الصوره من هناك بانتظار يعني
معرفه كيف ستكون الصوره بالساعات الماضيه
المقبله عفوا
شكرا لك زياد حلبي مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين على هذه الرساله
المعركه قوتنا تقوم بتوجيه ضربات قويه
وندمر كل من يمس بنا او يعمل ضدنا هذا هو
المبدا الذي نتعامل به في اطار عمليه
الدرع والسهم اوجدنا معادله جديده نقول
للمخربين ومرسليهم نراكم في كل مكان ولا
تستطيعون الاختباء ونحن نختار المكان
والزمان الذي نضربكم خلاله نحن ولستم انتم
بهدوء وليس رد فعل الخيار لنا انزلنا على
الجهاد الاسلامي في غزه اقوى ضربه في
تاريخه
السنه دخان وصفارات انذار وصواريخ تشق
طريقها نحو هدف مجهول لكن الرساله معلومه
مئه الصواريخ من قطاع غزه نحو المدن
الاسرائيليه تخرق حاله الصمت والترقب
وتدشن بدء رد حركه الجهاد الاسلامي على
سياسه الاغتيالات الاخيره التي استهدفت
عددا من قيادي الحركه الاعلام الاسرائيلي
قال ان مئات الصواريخ انطلقت من قطاع غزه
نحو مستوطناتهم تصدت لعدد منها القبه
الحديديه موجات القصف الصاروخي المكثفه
جاءت كرد سبق وتوعدت به حركه الجهاد
الحركه قالت انها مستعده لكل الاحتمالات
وهددت اسرائيل بما وصفته بايام سود في حال
تماديها
هذا الرد قابلته اسرائيل بغارات اخرى
استهدفت القطاع وبتصريحات لرئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو عن امكانيه توسيع الحمله
العسكريه على غزه
حاله من التوتر والتاهب والاستنفار فرضت
على المستوطنين الملاجئ وعلى الفلسطينيين
الصبر والتحمل الى حين الانتهاء من حمله
عسكريه تتصاعد الاحداث فيها نحو مصير
يتوعد به كل طرف الطرف الاخر لكن كما في
كل الحروب لا ينجاب الغبار عن حلبه
المعركه الا ومخلفا في اديمها ضحايا بين
المدنيين سلام المحاميد العربيه
[موسيقى]
قالت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز بعث دعوه الى الرئيس
السوري بشار الاسد لحضور القمه العربيه
المقرره في جده في التاسع عشر من مايو
المقبل وسلم السفير السعودي بالاردن
الدعوه الى الاسد الذي اكد من جهته ان
انعقاد القمه العربيه المقبله في السعوديه
سيعزز العمل العربي المشترك لتحقيق تطلعات
الشعوب العربيه
مسار تطبيع العلاقات التركيه السوريه في
العاصمه الروسيه موسكو انطلق والملفات
الساخنه بين الطرفين وضعت على الطاوله
لاول مره منذ 12 عاما موسكو راعيه
المصالحه والعرابه لهذه المصالحه طالبت
بخريطه الطريق لدفع مسار التقارب بين كل
من دمشق وانقره لضمان المتطلبات الامنيه
للاطراف كافه ولكن قبل اجتماع موسكو كشفت
وزاره الدفاع التركيه عن وجود مخطط لانشاء
مركز تنسيق ميداني مع النظام السوري هذا
المركز هو الاستمرار الخطه الخط الساخن
بين كل من روسيا ايران وتركيا واليوم
سيصبح مركزا للتنسيق الميداني ولكن بعدما
اصبح النظام السوري جزءا منه وفقا طبعا
مصادر سوريا اما ابرز اهداف مركز التنسيق
الميداني في سوريا فهو فهي طبعا تعزيز
الثقه المتبادله وتنسيق الميداني للانشطه
الموجوده في المنطقه كما قالت انقره هنا
فيما اكد الخبراء بانها محاوله تركيه
لضمان وقف اطلاق النار في ادلب واستجابه
النظام لجهود التركيه في مكافحه الارهاب
وضمان استقرار المنطقه امنيا وعسكريا
هنا تبدو المسافات قصيره بين انقره ودمشق
بعد اكثر من عقد على القطيع لكنها لا تبدو
قريبه في وجهات النظر وان جمعتهما طويله
واحده وسقف واحد ففي اول اجتماع على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه بين الجانبين تقترح روسيا
رسم خريطه الطريق لتطبيع العلاقات بينهما
قد تكون افضل نتيجه لتواصلنا هي الاتفاق
على توجيه الخبراء لاعداد مسوده خارطه
طريق للتطبيع بين سوريا وتركيا للاجتماع
الوزاري المقبل والتي سيتم ابلاغ رؤساء
دولنا بها
خريطه الطريق وفقا لموسكو تتضمن الالتزام
الثابت بالسياده جميع الدول المشاركه في
الاجتماع وسلامتها الاقليميه واستقلالها
ووحدتها والالتزام باهداف ومبادئ ميثاق
الامم المتحده واستعاده سريعه لعلاقات حسن
الجوار بين سوريا وتركيا على اسس المساواه
والمنفعه المتبادله اضافه الى ان الخريطه
ستسمح لدمشق وانقره بتحديد مواقفهما بوضوح
بشان القضايا ذات الاولويه بالنسبه لهما
الخريطه الروسيه تحدثت عن الخطوط العامه
لكنها لم تتطرق لنقاط الخلاف الجوهري بين
الجانبين التي يشكل انسحاب القوات التركيه
اهمها بنسبه لنظام السوري وبدونها سيبقى
الوضع يراوح مكانه كما يقول وزير الخارجيه
السوري بالمقابل تصر تركيا على قضيه
مكافحه الارهاب فهي ترى في وجود قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مبررا لبقائها العسكري
في سوريا وتامين حدودها وبين انقره ودمشق
يبدو الطريق باتجاه التطبيع مشوبا بخلافات
عميقه بحاجه لتنازلات لا يبدو الطرفان
مستعدين لتقديمها في الوقت الراهن
تتابعنا في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
زعيم المعارضه التركيه يتعهد بتطبيق
العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا اذا فاز
بالرئاسه
[موسيقى]
مع بقاء ايام قليله على بدء الانتخابات
التركيه تعهد زعيم المعارضه والمرشح
الرئاسي المنافس لاردوغان كمال كالجدار
اوغلو تعهد بانه سيطبق العقوبات الغربيه
على روسيا بشكل كامل اوغلو قال لوصف جرن
الامريكيه انه سيقرب تركيا من حيث شمال
الاطلسي والغرب اذا فاز في انتخابات يوم
الاحد كما انه سوف يسعى الى ضم تركي الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي مضيفا انه اذا انتصر
سيبث حياه جديده في الضوابط والتوازنات
الديمقراطيه في تركيا بعد سنوات قام
خلالها اردوغان بسجن المعارضين السياسيين
ليصبح اقوى زعيم تركي منذ قرن وفقا طبعا
قول اوكلو
[موسيقى]
مدينه اسطنبول ستقرر مصير من يحكم تركيا
ولاجل ذلك حرص الرئيس التركي اردوغان
وخصمه كمال
على اختيار هذه المدينه التاريخيه لمخاطبه
جمهور الطرفين اردوغان اختار مدرج مطار
اتاتورك الدولي القديم في اسطنبول حيث
تدفق الالاف من مناصريه للاستماع الى
خطابه الذي اكد فيه مجددا على ان اسطنبول
اذا قالت نعم فسينتصر بالتاكيد حسب تعبير
اردوغان طبعا كما اختار اوغلو الجانب
الاسيوي للمدينه وعقد تجمعه في حديقه تطل
على بحر مرمره ليخاطب مناصريه حيث يبلغ
عدد الناخبين في مدينه اسطنبول مشاهدينا
اكثر من 11 مليونا وهنا تتاكد اهميه هذه
المدينه لحسم الانتخابات كيف لا وهي التي
حسمت انتخابات البلديه الماضيه لصالح اك
اوغلو على حساب اردوغان وفريقه طبعا ايضا
الدعايه الانتخابيه في هذه الانتخابات
شهدت اساليب جديده بعيده عن الاساليب
التقليديه التي اعتدنا عليها في
الانتخابات ولفتت الانظار سواء كان في
الشارع او عبر شاشات التلفزه او مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي على سبيل المثال كما
نشاهد في هذه اللافته التي تظهر رسما
كاريكاتوريا لمرشح المعارضه لرئاسه
للرئاسه طبعا رئيس حزب الشعب الجمهوري
اوغلو وهو كما نشاهدون بهذه الصوره على
هيئه سبايدر مان بينما اختارت رئيسه حزب
الجيد ميرال اكشينار اسلوبا مميزا في
حملتها الدعائيه وادخلت ما يعرف
بالجرافيكس في اللافتا الرئيسيه لحملاتها
حيث وضعت الصوره صورتها هنا مع مؤسس تركيا
مؤسس الجمهوريه التركيه مصطفى كمال
اتاتورك وصورا تعبر عن مواطنين من مختلف
الفئات مع عباره تركيا ستكتب التاريخ
[موسيقى]
في مقابلات خاصه لقناه العربيه مع الزميل
طاهر بركه قال رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه
في ولايه اسطنبول عثمان نوريكا باكتابا
بان الحظ الاوفر بالحصول على اصوات فئه
الشباب التي اعتبرت اصوات مفصليه في
انتخابات عام 2023 هو من حظ حزب العداله
وتنميه
اكبر في مسيره 20 عاما كان عدد الناخبين
في اول انتخاب خاضه حزب العداله والتنميه
38 مليون ناخم والان بلغ هذا العدد 60
مليون ناخب تقريبا وفي اخر انتخاب خذناه
كان عدد الناخبين 54 مليونا تشير شركات
الاستطلاع المقربه من المعارضه الى ارتفاع
اصوات حزب العداله والتنميه الى 37
38 وتسعه وثلاثين بالمئه وهذا يدل على ان
الحظ الاوفر من هذه الفئه الناخبه الجديده
هو لصالح حزب العداله والتنميه
[موسيقى]
اعد مشاهدينا الى انضمام وعوده سوريا الى
جامعه الدول العربيه بعد تقريبا عقدين من
الزمن على تعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه
وينضم الي من دمشق الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
غسان يوسف استاذ غسان سابدا من الدعوه الى
جامعه الدول العربيه نحن نتحدث عن مبادره
عربيه قائمه على مبدا خطوه مقابل خطوه كيف
تلاقي اليوم دمشق العالم العربي بهذه
المبادره
تحياتي لك ولساده المشاهدين يعني طبعا
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه ممثلات
الخارجيه اصدر الديانا عندما عادت يعني
عندما تم قرار الاعاده يعني الرقم 89 14
بوقف تعليق كوريا في جامعه الدول العربيه
وقالت بان المهم اليوم هو الحوار والعمل
العربي
وان يكون هناك تفاهم على القضايا العربيه
سوريا دوله فاعله في هذا الحوار وفي هذا
التعاون واعتقد يعني ان سوريا تعرف يعني
مدى اهميه ان تكون ضمن الدول العربيه
ودوما يعني ضمن جامعه الدول العربيه اليوم
يعني بثلاثه الرئيس بشار الاسد هذه الدعوه
الكريمه من خادم الحرمين الشريفين اعتقد
ان الامور عادت الى نصابها من سوريا ستكون
دوله فاعله
وقادره على الالتزام بما يعني يطلب منها
عربيا وايضا هي لديها الكثير يعني من
المطالب من الدول العربيه وتعرفين يعني هي
هناك الكثير من القضايا التي مثلا تتعلق
بمكافحه الارهاب لمكافحه المخدرات
هذه المطالب بهذه المطالب هناك سله مطالب
عربيه ضمن المبادره والتقارب الحاصل اليوم
اتحدث عن يعني ضبط الميليشيات الموجوده
على الاراضي السوريه ضبط المخدرات ومعامل
الكبتاجون ضبط الحدود وايضا طبعا ملف عوده
اللاجئين كيف يعني
ستمضي سوريا بهذه الملفات التي تعتبر
اساسيه بمسار التقارب مع العالم العربي
هلا بشكل عام كانت سوريا دائما تقول يعني
بانها جاهزه للتعاون في كل هذه القضايا
وانها وحدها لا تستطيع مثلا عن تقضي على
الارهاب لا تستطيع مثلا ان تقضي على تهريب
المخدرات لا تستطيع مثلا ان تعيد اللاجئين
يعني عقدت ثلاث مؤتمرات اللاجئين لم تحضر
الدول العربيه المعنيه اليوم بعد يعني عرض
كوريا الدول العربيه يعني ستكون هي عضوا
فاعلا قادرا على الاقناع وقادرا على
الحوار وقادرا على يعني على اتخاذ
القرارات ولذلك انا اعتقد يعني بان هذه
العوده ووجود سوريا داخل لمنظمه جامعه
الدول العربيه سيكون يعني شيء ايجابي لان
سوريا لم تعد هي الدوله التي تتخذ بحقها
القرار في غيابها اليوم اصبح ضمن هذه
المنظومه هذا التقارب ايضا يعني هو تقارب
مضبوط ببعض المحاذير الغربيه التي ياتي من
ضمنها الحل السياسي ضمن المبادرات الامميه
ويعني الغطاء الاممي كيف ايضا ستتعاطى
سوريا مع هذا الملف
هلا اذا كنت تقصدين مثلا الحل السياسي
المبني على القرار 22 54 انا اعتقد يعني
بان سوريا وافقت على هذا القرار منذ صدوره
في ديسمبر 2015
وحاولت يعني مثلا انخرفت في مسار جنيه
ومسار التيتانها وفي لجنه الدستوريه
وحاولت بكل السبل والصعد ولكن لم يكن هناك
قرار فاعل من الدول المجاوره يعني سواء
الاقليميه او العربيه لم يكن هناك ضغط
يعني على المعارضه وتعرفهم بانها اغلب
المعارضات السوريه هي تعيش في دول الجوار
وايضا يعني مرتحنه لقرارات اجنبيه اليوم
تستطيع هذه الدول يعني الدول العربيه
والسقوطا مع التقارب التركي ان يكون لها
دور فاعل في هذا يعني في مثلا تطبيق
القناه
وتطبيق الحل السياسي ولكن انا اقول
بالنسبه لسوريا عندما يعني تلتزم بشيء
بهذا الشيء ولكن تراعي مصالحها الوطنيه
والكوميه ودائما كنا نسمع انتقادات يعني
مثلا اللجنه الدستوريه تصوري كان نصها
مرتها لتركيا يعني هل يجوز مثلا ان يكتب
الدكتور السوري بايادي خارجيه هذا لا يجوز
ولذلك يعني هناك صحيح ان سوريا مثلا توافق
بالمبدا على القرارات الدوليه ولكنها من
حقها ان تحتفظ بما يضمن يعني مثلا قيادتها
وحده اراضيها وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن مرحله
سياسيه جديده وعن عوده سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه والى يعني الحضنه العربي
بعد اكثر من عقد من تعليق عضويتها من
جامعه الدول العربيه شكرا لك غسان يوسف
حدثتنا من دمشق
[موسيقى]
في السودان والتطورات هناك حيث قالت قوات
الدعم السريع في مقطع فيديو انها اسقطت
الطائره حربيه تابعه للجيش السوداني في
منطقه بحري ياتي هذا بعد اشتداد المعارك
بين الطرفين فلنتابع
بدوره نشر الجيش السوداني فيديو يظهر فيه
تقدمه في منطقه بحري في العاصمه الخرطوم
بعد مشاهدت المنطقه عمليه اشتباك عنيفه
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
خمسه وعشرون يوما من الصراع في السودان
الاوضاع لا تزال على حاله لا بل تزداد
سوءا لاسيما الاوضاع الانسانيه منها
انتشال وانتشار كبير لحالات السطو والنهب
والصديقات في المناطق التي تتركز فيها
الاشتباكات بالعاصمه الخرطوم مستغلين طبعا
نزوح سكان تلك المناطق خوفا من الاشتباكات
كما تعرضت هنا مشاهدينا الكثير من الاسواق
والمحال التجاريه للصدقه جراء الانفلات
الامني ما دفع طبع المواطنين الى البحث عن
حلول لتامين احيائهم وممتلكاتهم بانفسهم
المنظمات الامميه هي الاخرى لم تسلم من
السرقات اذ تعرض مجمع رئيسي لبرنامج
الاغذيه العالميه في العاصمه السودانيه
للنهب والصدقه وفق تاكيدات الامم المتحده
اما ميدانيا فقد فشل كل من الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع في الالتزام باتفاقات
الهدنه المتكرره حيث تتواصل المعارك بين
الجيش والد عم السريع في الخرطوم مع سماع
طبعا ذوي انفجارات عنيفه وغارات جويه وسط
العاصمه فيما اكدت قوات الدعم السريع بان
القصر الرئاسي اصيب بضربه قويه جراء طبعا
غارات للجيش وهنا مشاهدينا اشار مراسل
العربيه الى رصد طلعات مكثفه لطيران الجيش
السوداني وذوي اسلحه ثقيله شرقي مدينه ام
درمان
[موسيقى]
الاشتباكات حتى الاصوات الاشتباكات
المتقطعه توقفت حاليا يسود تسود حاله من
الهدوء والسكينه
لا يوجد اي اشتباك في اي منطقه تبدل
المدينه هادئه بشكل كبير توقفت حركه
الطيران وكذلك الطيران الاستطلاع الذي كان
يحلق فيه ساعات الليل خلال الايام الماضيه
ولكن هناك حاله من الهدوء الكبير تسود
المدينه المواطنين الملتزمين
منازلهم الا من
الحركه الطفيفه في اطار
الحصول على الخدمات من بعض المتاجر او
صفوف المخابز او ما الى ذلك
شكرا لك شهد نادر حدثنا من ام درمان
كشفت مصادر مقربه من قائد الجيش السوداني
الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان ان الاخير
كان او كاد ان يفقد حياته خلال الساعات
الاولى من بدء الصراع على يد قوات الدعم
السريع بعد اقتحامها لمقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه وسط العاصمه الخرطوم مزيد
من التفاصيل في هذا التقرير
خلال ساعه الاولى من بدء صراع في السودان
كان قائد القوات المسلحه عبد الفتاح
البرهان في مواجهه مباشره كادت تنهي حياته
معلومات كشفتها وكاله رويترز للمره الاولى
تقول ان قوات الدعم السريع اشتبكت مباشره
مع البرهان وحراسه الشخصي في مقر القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني بعد عمليه اقتحام
شنها افراد من قوات الدعم السريع على
المبنى بحسب المعلومات التي نقلتها رويترز
عما وصفته بحارس شخصي للفريق اول عبد
الفتاح البرهان فان الساعات الاولى كانت
حاسمه في الصراع وتسببت بمقتل العشرات
وفقا لشهاده حارس البرهان فان القوات
المهاجمه قتلت 30 عنصرا من حراس البرهان
واجبرت المواجهه قائد الجيش على القتال
بنفسه بواسطه كلاشنكوف قبل ان ينقله حراسه
الى مكان امن لتنسحب قوات الدعم السريع من
المكان عقب
العمليه الخاطفه كشفت عن الاسلوب المفضل
لخصم البرهان الفريق اول محمد حمدان دقلو
المعروف باسم حميثي وهو القتال من مسافات
قريبه واستغلال نقاط القوه لدى قوته امر
قد يفسر استمرار تمدرس قوات الدعم السريع
في عده مناطق بالعاصمه السودانيه حتى
اللحظه وغير هذا وذا قد يفسر سبب تعنت كل
من الخصمين في الحسم العسكري فروايه
الساعات الاولى تقول انها بدات حاسمه
وبنيه القتل رائد المصطفى العربي
[موسيقى]
عرض السفير السعودي لدى اليمن محمد الجابر
في مقابله العربيه التكلفه الماليه
للبرنامج السعودي لتنميه واعمار اليمن
التي شملت محافظات يمنيه عده فلنتابع
مقاله ايضا هناك مشاريع في مارب ومشاريع
في حجه ومشاريع ايضا في صعده وايضا مشاريع
في الحديده ومشاريع في لحج وشبوه والضلع
وغيرها وصلنا تقريبا قرابه 500 مليون
دولار اقل من هذا الرقم بالنسبه للمشاريع
التنمويه والمبادرات شيء من هذا المشاريع
سلمت لسلطات المحليه والحكومه اليمنيه شيء
منها تحت الانجاز هناك ايضا مشاريع ب 480
دولار الان في الطريق بدانا في تنفيذ
بعضها والبعض الاخر تحت الطرح والبعض
الاخر تحت الدراسه ووضع اليوم الرئيس
دشنها اليوم كالبدء في التمييز بعضها
وايضا هناك مشاريع المنحه المنحه المشتقات
النفطيه سواء كانت ال 180 دولار في 2018
او420 مليون دولار في عام 2021 او 170
مليون دولار في العام الماضي
افتتح وفد في عدد مشاريع ضمن البرنامج
السعودي لتنميه واعمار اليمن في سبعه
قطاعات حيويه ضمنها 229 مشروعا ومبادره
تنمويه سعوديه
مشاريع وبرامج تنمويه في اليمن مبادرات
مستدامه تهدف الى تمويلها السعوديه عبر
برنامجها في سبعه قطاعات حيويه ضمن 229
مشروعا من بينها افتتاح مستشفى عدن العام
ومركز القلب الذي سيخدم نصف مليون سنويا
اضافه الى تدشين المرحلتين الاولى
والثانيه لمشروع اعاده تاهيل مطار عدن
الدولي من مدرج عدن رئيسي الى انظمه
الملاحه والاتصالات علما بان مشاريع اعمار
اليمن تجاوزت مليار دولار امريكي منذ عام
تستفيد منها اربعه عشره محافظه يمنيه
مشاريع من شانها ان تدفع عجله اقتصاد
اليمن وترفع كفاءه قطاعات البلاد
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من لندن بدر القحطاني
محرر الملف اليمني في جريده الشرق الاوسط
بدر اليوم يعني بعد مسار المصالحه اعاده
وضع اليمن على سكه اعاده الاعمار وكل
المشاريع السعوديه التي تهدف الى تغيير
الواقع اليمني الى واقع مختلف جدا ما
المامول منها وكيف سيكون المسار بالاشهر
المقبله
مساء الخير عليكم الساده المشاهدين اعتقد
ان هناك حاجه استراتيجيه كبرى من
الحكومه اليمنيه لهذا النوع من المشاريع
التنمويه لاننا اعتدنا طيله سنين الحرب
نرى عشرات الملايين ومئات الملايين من
الدولارات تسخرها الامم المتحده دائما
للمشاريع العاجله والطارئه وتتجدد كل سنه
هذا النوع من مشاريع التنميه التي يستهدف
البنى التحتيه ويستهدف المشاريع الكبرى
ويستهدف حتى المشاريع المتناهيه الصغر يص
في مساله تمكين الحكومه اليمنيه
واستدامه ادائها مهامها وهذا يمثل رافعه
كبيره جدا ان تمارس الحكومه اليمنيه دورها
وان يساعدها على ان توفي بالخدمات وان
تحسن طبيعه الحياه للسكان سعيا الى الهدف
الاستراتيجي الاكبر وهو تطبيع الحياه وخلق
نموذج جيد داخل المناطق المحرره والان نحن
نعيش في اجواء سلام اعتقد حتى الرسائل
السياسيه من زياره السفير السعودي الى عدن
وقبل اسابيع كان في صنعاء واعتقد ان هذا
كله يدفع نحو
التهدئه ويرسل رساله ايضا الى ان الامور
في اليمن من المهم جدا ان تحل وهي تجد
فرصه كبيره جدا لكي تتنفس هذه
اليوم نتحدث عن مشاريع مستدامه ليس فقط
لتمكين يعني الواقع البنيوي داخل اليمن
وانما ايضا اعاده تمكين الدوله واعاده
هيكله الدوله دوله حقيقيه بمؤسسات حقيقيه
تستطيع ان تلبي طموحات المواطن اليمني
اليوم لان طبعا الواقع الانماء يغير كثيرا
من واقع هذه الدوله بعد سنين الحرب كل هذا
كيف سيغير من واقع اليمن
اذا اذا من واقع الاتصالات التي نجريها
كثيرا بالناس ومراسلين على الارض ايضا
يتحدثون وينقلون في
تقاريرهم المواطن اليمني البسيط ربما لا
تهمه السياسه بقدر ما يهمه وجود مستشفى
بقد ما يهمه ان في ايام الطقس الساخر ان
تكون هناك مشتقات نفطيه تساعد السكان على
ان يكافحوا هذا الحرب الشديد في مناطق مثل
عدن ومناطق الساحليه المواطنين يريدون
الخدمات اولا قبل المكاسب السياسيه ربما
مكاسب السياسيه تقتصر على الاحزاب وعلى
اللاعبين السياسيين ولكن هذا النوع من
الخدمات كما تفضلت يعني يساعد الدوله
وايضا يوفر لها المساعده اللازمه لكي توفي
بالتزاماتها امام السكان لان سنين الحرب
اثقلت كاهل المواطن اليمني البسيط واصبح
حتى مجرد وجود ماء النظيف او توفر الغاز
والكهرباء اصبح نوعا من انواع الرفاهيه
وهذا ما اعت قد ان البرنامج السعودي تنميه
واعمار اليمن يساعد في الحكومه اليمنيه
على ان
يتجامل حياه المواطن اليمني وليس مجرد حلم
نحن نتحدث عن مرحله جديده عنوانها الماء
لليمن ولاهل اليمن شكرا لك من لندن بدر
القحطاني محرر الملف اليمني في جريده
الشرق الاوسط
مشاهدينا التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في خطوه تنافسيه لوتساب وماسنجر تويتر
تطلق قريبا خاصتي المكالمات والرسائل
المشفره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد طلبات الحكومه
الباكستانيه الجيش بتدخل الفوري لحفظ
الامن في العاصمه حيث تشهد الشوارع اعمال
شاغب واعتداءات على الاماكن العامه من قبل
مؤيدين رئيس الحكومه السابق عمران خان من
جهه اخرى قرر قاضي التحقيق تمديد احتجاز
عمران خان لمده ثمانيه ايام ورفض القاضي
طلب محاميه بالافراج عنه
بدوره اوضح وزير التخطيط الباكستاني بان
قرار اعتقال رئيس الحكومه السابق عمران
خان لم ياتي من دوافع سياسيه بل صدر عن
هيئه قضائيه مستقله عن الحكومه تتقصى
قضايا الفساد
اعلنت المحكمه العليا في اسلام اباد
توقيفه وفق اجراءات قانونيه سليمه وبموجب
السلطه القانونيه لذا فان عمليه الاعتقال
لم تكن بدوافع ايذاء سياسي الاعتقال لم
يكن بامر صادر عن الحكومه انه اعتقال من
قبل ديوان المحاسبه الوطني المؤسسه المنوط
بها التحقيق في قضايا الفساد في البلاد
وهي هيئه مستقله
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من اسلام اباد عبد
الرحمن المزيني مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
كيف هي الصوره الان من هناك يعني بالنهار
كنا نتحدث عن اشتباكات وعن عمليات حرق
وتخريب كيف هي الصوره واين هو عمران خان
الان
نعم الاشتباكات لا تزال متواصله والاعمال
الشاب والاحتجاجات التي يقوم بها انصار
رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان متواصله في
عدد من البؤر الاحتجاجيه في
مختلف المدن الباكستانيه لا سيما كاراتشي
وبشاور
ولاهور وايضا هنا في العاصمه اسلام اباد
كانت هناك عده بؤر احتجاجيه
لا سيما حول محيط
المجمع المجمع التابع للشرطه الباكستانيه
حيث جرت محاكمه رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان حاليا المحيط المجمع هناك حاله من
الهدوء النسبي في محيط مجمع الشرطه في
العاصمه لكن كانت هناك اشتباكات او
محاولات من قبل انصار عمران خان
لافتعال اعمال شغب وتم خلالها احراق بعض
من
التابعه للشرطه في احد احياء العاصمه او
الاحياء الخارجيه او المحيطه للعاصمه هنا
اسامه باد
ايضا كانت كانت هناك ايضا جرى احراق مبنى
راديو الباكستاني في مدينه بيشاور هناك
ايضا يعني بعد كل ما حدث اليوم كيف يعني
ما هي الخطوه اللاحقه
للاحزاب المعارضه ولحزب عمران خان غدا
وبالايام المقبله بما انه تمديد احتجازه
حزب عمران خان اكد بانه سوف يواصل
مظاهراته واحتجاجاته التي قال انها ستكون
سلميه حتى يتم الافراج عن رئيس الوزراء
السابق عمران خان كما نعلم قاضي المحكمه
مدد احتجاز عمران خان على ذمه التحقيق في
قضيه فساد لمده ثمانيه ايام وهو لا يزال
الان محتاجا في المجمع مجمع الشرطه الذي
اعلنته السلطات سجنا فرعيا
انصار رئيس الوزراء السابق لا يزالون في
الشوارع في عدد من المدن الباكستانيه لكن
عاده ساعات الليل تشهد انحسارا في اعدادهم
اود الاشاره هنا الى انه بالفعل بدات الان
بدا وصول بعض طلائع القوات التابعه للجيش
الباكستاني بدات تدخل في بعض المناطق في
العاصمه وتتسلم ربما مهمتها في حفظ الامن
والسلام والسلام هنا في العاصمه اسلام
اباد يتوقع ربما في في غضون الساعات
المقبله ايضا ان يتم ايضا نشر قوات اخرى
من الجيش وفقا للطلب الذي تقدمت به حكومتي
اقليم خيبر بختون وحكومه
الاعتقال بما اننا كنا نتحدث عن اعتقال
الالاف خلال الساعات الماضيه عبد الرحمن
هناك ايضا سؤال اساسي تصريح وزير الداخليه
والذي قال فيه بان عمران خان ليس فقط متهم
بفساد انما يعمل مع قوه خارجيه وايضا قوى
يعني تعمل ضد السياده الباكستانيه كيف
تلقفت الاحزاب المعارض معارضه هذا الاعلان
حقيقه هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يصرح
فيها مسؤول في الحكومه الباكستانيه بان
عمران خان يعمل وفق اجنده خارجيه تهدف الى
ممكن
ان يكون يعني هذه الاتهامات تطيل من فتره
احتجاز يعني ابقائه محتجز
نعم بالفعل اعتقال عمران خان في في ما جرى
امس سوف يفتح المجال امام التحقيق معه في
عده عده قضايا عمران خان كان يقاوم
اعتقاله خلال الاشهر الماضيه هناك نحو 100
قضيه مسجله 100 قضيه وبلاغ مسجله ضد رئيس
الوزراء السابق حاول خلال الاشهر الماضيه
بل نجح في الافلات من الاعتقال في اكثر من
مره حصل على عده مذكرات او عفوا على عده
كفالات ضد الاعتقال في عدد من القضايا لكن
الان بما انه تحت قبضه السلطات فمن
المتوقع ان يتم فتح العديد من القضايا
والتحقيق معه فيها وربما توجيه لائحه
الاتهام له في عدد من القضايا كما جرى
بالفعل اليوم في ما يعرف بقضيه الهدايا
التي يتهم بها
بالاستحواذ على هدايا للدوله بطريقه غير
شرعيه ايضا
الاحتجاجات هذه التي تجري الان السلطات
تقوم الان بحصر الاضرار التي جرت
في الممتلكات او حتى الخسائر البشريه
واعداد ربما قضيه جديده
الارهاب عن لائحه يعني
اتهامات
سنتابعها معك طبعا من هناك في الساعات
المقبله عبد الرحمن المزيني مراسل العربيه
شكرا لك من اسلام ابد
[موسيقى]
قالت صحيفه
ان شركات تكنولوجيه ناشئه وصغيره بدات
تنافس شركات عملاقه في صناعه الاسلحه
واثبتت تلك الاسلحه جدوها في ساحه
اوكرانيا خلال الحرب الدائره للعام الثاني
على التوالي
في الساحه الاوكرانيه امدادات عسكريه لا
تتوقف اسلحه تقليديه واخرى تفرض نفسها
عسكريا
تقول صحيفه فاين تايمز ان تغييرات تجتاح
الصناعات الدفاعيه وصراعا يهز شركات
الاسلحه التقليديه العملاقه
شركات الاسلحه الكبرى تواجه تحديات من
وافدين جدد شركات ناشئه تتقدم بسرعه وتسهم
بتغييرات اوسع في تجارات الاسلحه الصحيفه
استعرضت بعض ابرز الاسلحه التي تحتل مكانه
في الساحه الاوكرانيه الاقمار الصناعيه
المستعاره تعمل بالطاقه الشمسيه طويله
التحمل تستخدم للمراقبه الطائرات بدون
طيار السلاح الذي اثبت فعاليته قبل الحرب
في اوكرانيا حتى المسيرات الانتحاريه او
المتسكعه طائره صغيره الحجم مذخره
العربات المسيره تؤدي مهام متعدده
كالاستطلاع والقتال وازاله الالغام واجلاء
الضحايا توفر تلك الاسلحه ميزه تفتقر لها
التقليديه كخفتها ومرونه توريدها اضافه
الى الفعاليات العسكريه المعتمده على
معلومات اجهزه الاستشعار ومعالجه البيانات
والحوسبه منتجات عسكريه يرى خبراء انها
تحقق رغبه المشترين في الحصول على
تكنولوجيا افضل ومتطوره باسعار معقوله
لم تكن اوروبا مستعده لحرب على حدودها
وفاجاتها الحروب في اوكرانيا ولاجل ذلك
كان عاما صعبا على الاتحاد الاوروبي
والعالم وقع الحال هذا جاء على لسان رئيس
الشؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
واوروبا هنا طبعا قيمت الواقع المعقد في
اوكرانيا ووجدت ان العالم منقسم وسط صدام
كبير بين القوتين العظمتين اي الولايات
المتحده من جهه والصين من جهه اخرى وهي
تريد وتسعى الى تحقيق السلام العادل في
اوكرانيا وهنا بدا لافتا جدا حديث برال عن
الدور الايجابي الذي يمكن ان تلعبه الصين
بهذا الخصوص بعدما اثبتت الوقائع
الميدانيه في حرب اوكرانيا بان بيكين لم
تقدم اسلحه لروسيا حتى الان طبعا هنا
الحديث ليبرل دور الصين المهم والمؤثر في
انهاء الحرب الاوكرانيه تحدثت عنه ايضا
تحدث عنه طبعا ايضا وزير
الامريكيه
الاسبقر لمجله نيوزويك معتبرا انابيكيا
ستساعد في تغيير امد الحرب بحلول نهايه
العام وذلك عبر مفاوضات سلام بين كل من
روسيا واوكرانيا برعايه طبعا بدات طلائع
المكالمه الهاتفيه بين الرئيس الصيني
ونظيره الاوكراني لمده ساعه افضل عن اجواء
ايجابيه بين الرجلين فضلا طبعا عن تعيين
سفير لاوكرانيا لدى الصين مما سيدفع بقوه
لتنميه العلاقات الثنائيه بين البلدين
وفقا طبعا
وهنا لابد من الاشاره مشاهدينا بان سياسه
اوروبا تجاه الصين تغيرت نهائيا وشاهدنا
ذلك مع زياره الرئيس الفرنسي مع ريال ما
كون الى الصين ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
ارسنال فوندر لاين الى بكين طبعا وقبلها
زياره المستشار الالماني ور ئيس الوزراء
الاسبانيه
[موسيقى]
تويتر دخل على خط المنافسه مع فيسبوك
وواتساب حيث ستوفر الشركه خصائي المكالمات
والرسائل المشفره في وقت قريب وفق ما كشفه
الى ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لتويتر المزايا
الجديده ستشمال المحادثات الصوتيه مع اي
شخص على منصات وتويتر في اي مكان من دون
اعطاء رقم الهاتف الشخصي هذا واكدت شركه
تويتر بانها ستبدا عمليه تطهير لحذف ارشفه
حسابات غير ناشطه منذ
وفي اخبار التكنولوجيا ايضا يصوت اعضاء
البرلمان الاوروبي على حظر التعرف عن
التعرف على الوجه عن طريق الذكاء
الاصطناعي في الشوارع والذي ينظر اليها
المشرعون على انه اختبار رئيسي في تشكيل
اول قوانين الذكاء الاصطناعي في العالم
[موسيقى]
اطلقت منظمه الصحه العالميه بالتعاون مع
اليونيسيفط حاله طوارئ فيما يخص بزياده
اعداد الاجنه المتوفين قبل الولاده وايضا
ارتفاع الولادات المبكره بعواقب صحيه ما
ادى الى ان تصبح الولادات المبكره سبب
رئيسي لوفاه الاطفال تحت سن الخامسه
فلنتابعها
[موسيقى]
موت في الارحام اعداد الاجنه المتوفاه في
ازدياد
[موسيقى]
وفاه مليون طفل من مضاعفات ما قبل الولاده
اطفال وان نجوا يولدون مبكرا غير سليمين
حاله طوارئ صامته اطلقتها منظمات انسانيه
اعلنت عن 152 مليون طفل ضعيف في العقد
الاخير
نحو 13 مليون و400 الف طفل ولدوا مبكرا في
سبب رئيسي للوفاه تحت سن الخامسه
[موسيقى]
وفاه اكثر من واحد من كل خمسه اطفال بسبب
الولاده المبكره بعواقب صحيه
مستوى الدخل عامل اساسي
اكثر من خمسه وستين في المئه من الحالات
في جنوب اسيا وافريقيا جنوب الصحراء
تلوث الهواء يساهم في سته ملايين ولاده
مبكره في كل عام
الختام مشاهدينا مع العناوين
[موسيقى]
تصعيد بين الفصائل الفلسطينيه والجيش
الاسرائيلي ونتنياهو يقول ان المعركه لم
تنتهي بعد
الملك سلمان يوجه دعوه للرئيس السوري
لحضور قمه الجامعه العربيه القادمه في جده
اشتباكات واصوات انفجارات عنيفه في
الخرطوم وتدهور الامني يؤدي لانتشار السطو
والنهب
تحسبا لتصعيد محتمل من انصار عمران خان
الحكومه الباكستانيه تطالب الجيش بتدخل
لحفظ الامن
التاسع انتهت مشاهدينا لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل ليله والان الى 360
والزميله راويه راويه مساء الخير ماذا
لديك اهلا بك طبعا سنتحدث عن التصعيد بسعه
الاخيره بين الجانبين الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي وكذلك الاوضاع الميدانيه في
بحمود تبعينا تفضلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات